Two words you'll hear thrown
a lot in macroeconomic circles
are monetary policy
and fiscal policy.
And they're normally talked
about in the context of ways
to shift aggregate demand
in one direction or another
and often times to kind of
stimulate aggregate demand,
to shift it to the right.
And what I want to
do in this video
is focus on what these
two different tools who
are, who are the
actors, and how do
they go about actually shifting
the aggregate demand curve.
So monetary policy--
this is literally
deciding how much
money to print.
So it's literally
printing money--
either deciding to print more
of it or deciding to print less.
It tends to be done
in the United States--
especially in most
large countries-- it's
done by the central bank,
which is sometimes directly
part of the government.
Sometimes it's
quasi-independent.
In the US, it's a quasi--
The US central bank, which
is the Federal Reserve,
is quasi-independent.
And in future videos
we'll talk more
about the governance structure
of the Federal Reserve.
Most of the major appointees
are made by the US government.
All of its excess profits
goes back to the US Treasury,
so in that way it's part
of the US government.
But it's set up to be--
also has some influence
from private industry.
The member banks have a
stake in what's going on.
It often coordinates
amongst member banks.
So you have your Federal
Reserve as a central bank
in the United States.
It's quasi-independent,
but it's been
given the right to print money.
And I'll just draw it
here as physical dollars,
but most of the money that
is going to print actually
is electronic money.
And the way this affects
the aggregate demand curve,
the Federal Reserve
doesn't just print money
and go out and start buying
things with that money.
Well, it does buy
things, but it doesn't
go out and buy
goods and services.
What it does with this is
it essentially lends it out,
so it's essentially buying debt.
And if buying debt seems like a
weird thing to say, buying debt
it is the same thing
as lending money.
If I buy a treasury bond,
so if I'm buying debt,
I'm buying a treasury
bond means I'm implicitly
lending that money.
If I buy the bond directly
from the government,
that means I'm lending that
money to the US government.
If I directly buy a bond
from a US corporation,
I'm essentially lending that
money to the corporation.
They're going to give
me interest payments
in the form of coupons,
and then they're
going to pay back that
money at some future date.
So this is essentially
lending money.
And what this does is it's
increasing the supply of money
that's out there to be lent.
And so if we think of the
market for money-- so let's
see, now we're thinking
microeconomic terms
for the market for money.
If this is the price of
money, which is really
just the interest
rate as a percentage,
and this right over here
is the supply of money.
And I'll just draw-- so this
might be our supply curve.
That's supply.
And this is the demand curve.
And let's say right over here,
this is short-term money.
And we won't focus on the
different durations and all
of that.
But let's say we're
sitting right over here
at a clearing
interest rate of 5%.
So it makes sense.
So this is right here.
This is our demand curve.
So all of the people who will
get more than 5% benefit out
of the money-- maybe they have
an investment where they could
get 10% on the money
or 8% or 5.1%--
they're all willing to borrow
that money and then invest it
in whatever they want to do.
Or this might even
be consumption,
people who are saying, hey, 5%.
That's worth it for
me to go out and buy
that thing that makes
me whatever happy.
But from an investment point of
view it makes even more sense.
If I'm going to get an 8%
return on my money-- that's
my benefit-- it makes sense
for me to borrow it at 5%.
It makes sense all
the way up to 5.0001%.
I'd actually borrow it.
And so in the Federal
Reserve, or any central bank,
prints money and it buys debt.
It goes out into debt
markets and it usually
buys the safest kind
of debt, but that
affects all of the debt markets.
It goes out and
buys debt market.
They're essentially shifting
the supply curve of money
to the right.
They shift the supply
curve to the right.
And so at any
given interest rate
you could say that
there is more money.
And so the supply curve might
look something like that.
And this is interesting because
assuming the demand has not
shifted, what you now have
is a different clearing
price, a different equilibrium
price, for the money.
Maybe this is now at 3%.
And you also have more money
being lent and borrowed.
So if this was the
old quantity of money
that was lent and
borrowed-- I'm just
going to make up a number here.
Let's say that this is $100
billion in some time period.
And now we're at $120 billion.
So now by essentially printing
money, buying debt, increasing
the supply of money
two things happen.
Interest rates went down.
And so now you have
all of these characters
out here who before, they
weren't going to borrow money
at 5% because their
benefit on that money
was between 5% and 3%.
Maybe it's 4% or 3.5%.
It didn't make sense
for them to borrow at 5%
and invest it and only get
a 4% return or a 3% return.
But now that interest
rates have gone down,
now it does make sense for
them to borrow the money,
all the way down to someone
who has some type of project
or investment that
has a 3% return.
They also say, hey, I'm neutral.
Now I could borrow at 3%,
and then I could invest it.
But definitely the
person with 3.1% or 3.2%,
if they have investments
that give them that much,
they would definitely
want to borrow.
And we could assume that all
this incremental borrowing--
so this little example that
I did right over here--
all this incremental
$20 billion of borrowing
is going to be spent.
People will borrow
money not to just sit
but stuff it into
their mattresses.
They'll borrow that money
to go invest it in some way,
to spend it.
And so what this
will do, all of this
will shift aggregate
demand to the right.
Right here, we're talking
in microeconomic terms,
but then if we think about
aggregate supply and demand--
so this is aggregate.
Let me write aggregate
right over here.
This is price.
This is real GDP.
This is our aggregate demand.
And then our short run aggregate
supply might look something
like this.
And so if we're shifting
aggregate demand
to the right where there's going
to be more demand for goods
and services, these people
are going to borrow this money
and spend it.
You're going to essentially
stimulate the economy.
So this shifts to the right.
You have a situation where real
GDP will go from this state
to this state right over here.
So it was expansionary.
And obviously, if the
Federal Reserve decides
to print less money
or if they even
decide to essentially soak up
the money that's in the market
by selling some of the
debt that they own,
so that they're sucking
dollars out of it,
then the opposite
effect would happen.
Now fiscal policy is
essentially the government
directly going out there and
demanding goods and services
from the economy.
You have the government.
It has two sources of
revenue that it can spend.
It has money from taxes.
It has tax revenue.
And then it can go
out and borrow money.
And so it also has
access to debt markets.
And when the government
borrows money,
they're essentially
issuing treasury bills,
if you're talking about the
US Treasury Bills and Treasury
Bonds.
If you were to buy those
from the US government,
you're essentially lending
money to the government
to finance their debt.
And so they can take these
two sources of money,
and then if they decide
to spend more-- and let's
say that they're going
to hold taxes fixed.
So they're not going to take
out any demand from the economy.
They might ratchet up debt
and then ratchet up spending.
And then this
government is directly
going out there and demanding
more goods and services.
So that could also shift
the aggregate demand curve
to the right.
So these are two different
levers, two different tools,
that have been
used in governments
all around the world to shift
aggregate demand one way
or another or an attempt to
shift aggregate demand one
way or the other.
Monetary policy
is more indirect.
Printing money, using that to
increase the supply of money
that's out there to be lent,
that lowers interest rates.
And then because it
lowers interest rates,
there's more willingness to
borrow and invest that money.
Fiscal policy, you're directly
going out there and just buying
more goods and services
by usually ratcheting up
your debt.
Or fiscal policy could
go the other way.
If you're trying to restrain
the economy, you could lower
your debt, lower
your spending, or you
could do some other
combination. s